Bonjour. J'ai rencontré il y a
quelques jours à l'IFA de Berlin
la société française Wiko pour parler de
de ses nouveaux smartphones
les modèles View, View Prime et View XL.
Ces smartphones sont sympas et
je vais vous les présenter.
Si vous ne me connaissez pas je
m'appelle Monsieur GRrr.
Ma chaîne traite de stratégie digitale, de
stratégie Youtube pour vous aider
à aller plus loin dans votre vie digitale
et dans votre stratégie sur Youtube.
Je vous invite à vous abonner à ma chaîne et à
activer la cloche pour ne manquer aucune publication.
J’ai rencontré cette société marseillaise à Berlin sur leur stand.
Un stand qui était grandiose.
J’ai pu tester et voir ces smartphones,
les nouveaux View.
Les produits sont super bien.
Je vous emmène à Berlin avec moi pour en parler.
Wiko vient de lancer
trois nouveaux produits tops.
Il y a tout d'abord le View.
Ce smartphone là. Le View XL qui est la
version XL avec un écran plus grand.
Et le View Prime
qui a pleins de qualités.
Le View a un écran 5,7 pouces en 18:9. C’est un
produit vraiment très agréable à prendre en main.
Il a une caméra 13 mégapixels à l'arrière et
sur l'avant, une caméra en 16
mégapixels.
Elle est parfaite pour faire des vidéos.
La qualité est extrêmement bonne à
l’avant. Lorsque vous
filmez vos vidéos, vous
allez vous voir dans une
excellente qualité en ayant un vrai
retour moniteurs. C’est super.
Il a un processeur quatre coeurs.
Ce produit offre de nombreuses fonctionnalités différentes.
Vous pouvez le déverrouiller grâce au capteur
présent à l’arrière.
Il est très pratique à la différence
d'autres produits concurrents
où vous avez toujours le risque de mettre votre
doigt sur la caméra.
Ici le capteur est placé en dessous,
cela permet une prise en main vraiment
très facile et très agréable.
Il y a le View et le View XL. La grande différence avec
le modèle XL est la taille de l’écran.
Il a un écran de presque 6 pouces : 5,99 pouces.
Ils ont les mêmes spécifications techniques entre le View et le View XL.
La différence est la taille de l'écran.
Il a 32Go de mémoire et 3Go de RAM.
Le View a une batterie de 2900 mAh et
le XL de 3000 mAh.
Ils sont disponibles en quatre couleurs :  noir, or, turquoise et rouge.
Ce modèle c'est le View Prime mais cette couleur est disponible
également sur le View et le View XL.
Le View Prime est un
produit qui est très intéressant parce qu'il a beaucoup de
qualités et notamment pour
la vidéo. C’est un produit qui a
un écran 5,7 pouces avec un ratio 18:9.
64Go de mémoire et 4Go de RAM.
Une batterie 3000 mAh. La
prise en main est vraiment très sympa.
Il a à l’arrière un capteur pour le déverrouiller rapidement.
A l’arrière il a une
caméra 16 mégapixels avec un flash
et à l'avant il a
l’avantage d'avoir une double caméra.
Il a une caméra 20 mégapixels
et 8 mégapixels.
Cela vous permet de filmer avec une très
bonne qualité sur la caméra selfie
mais aussi d'avoir un très grand angle.
Ici je filme avec la caméra de 8 mégapixels.
L’affichage est standard comme sur la majorité des smartphones.
Maintenant Je vais tester la caméra
grand-angle en 20 mégapixels.
On constate une vraie différence.
La qualité d'image est là
et c'est vraiment très pratique.
Il existe aussi une
fonctionnalité pour avoir un fond flou,
un aspect blur sur vos images.
Cela permet de vous faire ressortir par rapport
à votre fond. C’est très esthétique.
Ce produit a la particularité de ne pas être cher.
Il coûte 269 euros et sera disponible à partir de fin septembre.
Le rapport qualité - prix est vraiment bien.
Je n’ai rien à reprocher à ce téléphone.
Il est très bien conçu.
De plus il a la particularité
d'être fabriqué en France.
Voilà ce que l’on peut dire aujourd'hui
sur ces trois modèles : View, View Prime
et View XL. Ils sont équipés du
processeur Snapdragon 425. Pour résumer
les 3 modèles ont la même base.
Le View XL a 1 écran
plus grand que le View.
Et le View Prime est mieux équipé.
Le view coûte 179,99 euros.
Le View XL 229,99 euros.
Le View Prime : 279 euros. A moins de 300
euros vous avez un smartphone avec
Android 7.1 Nougat, avec des
caméras de bonne qualité.
Un processeur performant. Un téléphone
convenable.
Vous n’aurez pas les nouvelles technologies
de déverrouillage.
Vous n'aurez pas tous
les gadgets mais si vous voulez
un bon smartphone fabriqué en France,
pas cher, n’hésitez pas.
Cette nouvelle gamme de View saura vous
séduire.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Dites-moi ce que vous pensez
de ces téléphones : View, View XL, View Prime.
Aimeriez-vous en avoir un ?
Vous séduisent ils ?
Commentez la vidéo et on discute ensemble. Je
vous invite à vous abonner à ma chaîne
car il y aura toujours plus de contenu pour
vous aider dans votre stratégie Youtube
et votre stratégie digitale.
Si vous avez des questions vous pouvez
me joindre sur Twitter @MonsieurGRrr
et avec le hashtag #ASKMonsieurGRrr
Je vous dis à très
bientôt et d'ici là portez vous bien.
Salut !